bro
so today i listened to six episodes of
that [ __ ] theranos
elizabeth holmes [ __ ] did you watch that
what did you did you
watch the hbo documentary or i didn't
watch the hbo one i i mean i've i've
read a couple articles
and um i read like three articles and i
saw
a i've seen two documentaries on her
really
yeah which ones did you see i didn't
know there was more than one oh yeah
there's one that's like an
hour maybe it's like 50 minutes it's
right around an hour it's um
yeah i listened to like i listened to
like six hours of [ __ ] podcast that
was uh
it was one of those like serial type
podcasts she's
crazy right bro that [ __ ] is [ __ ] up
but about the way she lowers her voice
so that's the creepiest and the the
the um the the the the turtleneck oh
yeah like stevie
steve jobs yeah she's trying to be like
steve jobs she raised almost a billion
dollars
yeah she's like 24 years old she was
worth four billion dollars on paper
on paper on paper yeah that's when you
get out with all the money she got
rupert murdoch to give her
like 150 million doing what
she came out she went to which she go to
stanford she went to stanford and she
dropped out
for three semesters yeah went to
stanford
decided that she was going to do a come
up with a technology company medical
technology company
that would allow you to give a pin prick
of blood
and would allow it to be run through 300
different tests
to tell you exactly what's going on with
you and your you know everything about
you three three
the basic the base 300 tests that are
out there this machine will run
all of them and so she's going around
talking about technology and doing this
she forms a company
she actually gets a neighbor to give her
a million dollars right
a a neighbor yeah gives her made a bunch
of money
and she sat down and explained and she's
always been super smart
so and her parents her dad was in like
politics in dc
and her mom was like her family was in
politics and her
she had some like lineage where her
grandparents like used to be rich
but not anymore and they still have the
prestige they had the prestige but they
didn't have the money
right and uh they interviewed one of her
friends from like middle school in high
school
and said she was kind of like the loner
she didn't really have any friends she
was always by herself she was
like the last one in gym classes she
kind of get caught lying a few times
like like
like telling some some fabrications and
and she just she was just off like off
pretty girl yeah pretty girl pretty
smart
i don't know yeah she was weird looking
though she was like a a female
mark zuckerberg she had that look she
had those like dead eyes like
mark zuckerberg i think she's got those
wide eyes with like
the whole time like this yeah and
there's multiple cases like oh
let me explain what i did all of a
sudden she just started changing her
voice she's like started like
trying to make her voice deeper to be
like they think
yeah uh veritas whatever my company is
named uh we we are you know
amazing we're pushing the boundaries we
want to be the best uh women
women need to be the best we want to
push women's is that your baritone
well i have to do it more like this yeah
it was lower she was faking it that's
like i know she
but no but she would fake it and then
every once while somebody would say
something she'd go
well like no that's not what happened i
didn't um uh
she would switch yeah periodically
they'd catch her accidentally switching
and employees said by the end of the day
she would do it when she's tired
she'd forget to throw the [ __ ] nuts
she was dating a guy that was like 40
something years old she was in her early
20s dating like a 45 year old
the indian guy who gave her 14 million
bucks drove a lambo everywhere
they
so the point is yeah he was he was
filthy rich sunny
sunny yeah indian dude named sunny who
made a bunch of money in like the dot
com
dot com bubble and uh
she was elizabeth what i always want to
say elizabeth holmes holmes
i always want to say smart yeah um so
she raised like
almost a billion dollars she hired all
these people all these like computer
scientists research scientists these
laboratory
[ __ ] people and she had all these
scientists working on
developing this thing that was in a box
where it would basically take your blood
with a finger prick and it would tell
you everything about
you basically everything from your
cholesterol
to your like the different cancers you
could potentially have and
everything about your health your
metabolic health everything 300
different tests within one drop of blood
but they never actually worked no
because it's not possible
it wasn't possible she hired apple
designers she hired [ __ ] who
designed iphones for apple
[ __ ] that worked for steve jobs
like
all these people don't know that it
doesn't work they all figured it out
eventually and they were all like what
the [ __ ] going on like
they do all these tests and like they're
all failing or
a very few of them are actually working
but the ones that do work
the blood tests are way off yeah they're
right they were like across the spectrum
some
sometimes you know they were erratic
like they weren't they weren't accurate
they were not accurate
yeah so there's all these red flags
happening and like all the tech like
tests were off half
more than like 90 of them weren't
working at all right but she's like oh
make them look nice make them look like
an
iphone we're going to market it we're
going to hire we're going to get all
this vc money
we're going to we're going to get vc
it's like silicon valley [ __ ] like scam
who was it was it was it well venture
capitalists
aren't scams all of them kind of are
scams though
because all of them if i landed do you
think she started it as a scam from the
get-go
no i think i think she had tried it i
think she
got too far i think she was running with
fake it till you make it like
exactly like what we can do is if i
raise enough money we'll we'll
put the it'll actually work yeah we'll
hire the bet and she's hiring the best
yeah she's paying tons of money
we'll dump all this money into research
and development we'll get this to work
but the fact of the matter is is
yeah we will in a hundred years they
even hire now
she even hired the ad agency who made
that original apple 1984 commercial i
love that
where their throat she throws the hammer
at the screen or whatever
they hired then they paid them they paid
them like a 14 million dollar retainer
to run a whole ad to run a whole ad
campaign on how the thing worked
with only a drop of blood but yet it
didn't work yet
they were just trying to get everything
was it walgreens
was it wall street walgreens dumped
three they started with a hundred
million and then i think it went up to
three hundred million dollars it was
walgreens and somebody else
just walgreens i think i think i thought
it was walgreens and cvs or something
nope just walgreens
300 million they got they only got into
41 walgreens though
um and they basically cut the deal with
walgreens but they didn't it didn't
[ __ ] work so what they were doing was
people were going into walgreens
and they marketed this trick [ __ ] up
tests they marketed this
on for 10 years this wasn't a year this
was 10 years she's living large for 10
years yeah
is she living the good life out there
too the whole time
i mean sure yeah i think so well all her
interviews like i don't sleep
i don't all i do is work i don't even
own a tv all i do is work work work
24 7 work that's why i'm so rich that's
why i'm so successful and then she
started getting on like she's like the
money is
trying to bang that 14 million out he
knows by now he knows it's over yeah
sonny knows it's over yeah
listen within six months a year maybe
two maybe you could go two years
but after two three years he's got to be
known
he's in the meetings he has to start
knowing he drove a lamborghini
the weird a weird thing i thought i was
there on the and she's going to trial on
the podcast yeah she's about to go to
trial
what are you doing what are you doing
you can't go to trial
you know she's trying to say i'm now
she's trying to say mental illness
yeah is she going to be her own lawyer
hell no
i can't imagine she's could do the
things such a cluster
doesn't have it's like it's funny it's
like a ted bundy when i got my lawyer
and all these guys were like were like
man bro
your lawyer had you plead to 26 and a
half years i'm like
i mean well i didn't give her anything
to work with
yeah what was she's a good lawyer if
you're look
if you're caught with the dead body and
the smoking gun
and you're on video 26 is good it
doesn't
matter who the lawyer is i love it when
people think that well with a good
lawyer
what are you talking about with a good
lawyer it's they're not magicians
yeah oj got off that's true they're
saying a bunch of federal prosecutors
said that they haven't seen anybody like
this [ __ ] since bernie madoff
yeah she's she's in in oh what about the
the the scare tactics and the firings
and
oh right oh she's like anybody bullied
people like threatened
people like if anyone ever tried to like
question her like
hey this shit's not working uh i'm kind
of concerned like
get your [ __ ] people are getting blood
tests and it's saying they could have
like
extreme levels of of certain things in
their blood and they're freaking out
thinking they got cancer and people are
like
like going to the doctor and freaking
out about their health because these
blood tests are so inaccurate
like how dare you question our integrity
you're fired
oh god how do you think you've got to
lower your
baritone yeah you have to watch it yeah
it was
all lies what's it called uh the one on
the one i listened to was called
on spotify what was it called what the
[ __ ] was it it was like an abc
podcast i'll get you the short version
that's crazy yeah
i've listened to something she's got a
bunch of hbo
it's probably one of the largest frauds
out there yeah not the largest but one
current that's the crazy
thing it's current well it's yeah it's
because it's about
like three four years ago she got i mean
they've been out on pre-trial release
i think they started the company like
2010. no she's free
she's free right now yeah she's living
in san francisco i don't think
can it be 10 2010 i thought they i i
thought she'd gone like
10 years like this was dragging off for
10 years
i